can you try to introspect your
particular biological neural network
your thinking process and describe how
you think
through problems the different
engineering and design problems is there
like a systematic process you've spoken
about first principles thinking but is
there kind of process to it well um
you know like saying like like physics
is law and everything else is a
recommendation
um like i've met a lot of people who can
break the law but i haven't met anyone
who could break physics
so uh so first for you know any kind of
technology problem you have to sort of
just make sure you're not
violating
physics um
and
you know uh
first principles analysis i think is
something that can be applied to
really any walk of life uh any anything
really it's just it's it's really just
saying um
you know let's let's well something down
to the most fundamental
uh
principles the things that we are most
confident are true at a foundational
level
and that sets you at your sets your
axiomatic base and then you reason up
from there and then you cross check your
conclusion against the the axiomatic
truths
um
so
um you know some basics in physics would
be like are you violating conservation
of energy or momentum or something like
that you know then
you're it's not gonna work um
so
uh that's
you know so that's just to establish is
it is it possible
another good physics tool is thinking
about things in the limit if you if you
take a particular thing and you
uh
scale it to a very large number or to a
very small number how does how do things
change
um well it's like tempo like in number
of things you manufacture or something
like that and then in time
yeah like let's say say take example of
like um
like manufacturing which i think is just
a very underrated
problem um
and and
uh likes it it's much harder to
take
a an advanced technology product and
bring it into volume manufacturing than
it is to design it in the first place my
borders magnitude so
um
so let's say you're trying to figure out
is
like why is this
this uh part or product
expensive is it um
because of something fundamentally
foolish that we're doing or is it
because our volume is too low and so
then you say okay well what if our
volume was a million units a year is it
still expensive
that's what i mean by thinking about
things to the limit if it's still
expensive at a million units a year then
volume is not the reason why your thing
is expensive there's something
fundamental about design
and then you then can focus on the
reducing complexity or something like
that and change the design to change the
change apart to be something that is uh
uh
not fundamentally expensive
but but like that's a common thing in
rock tree because the the unit volume is
relatively low and so a common excuse
would be well it's expensive because our
unit volume is low um and if we were in
like automotive or something like that
or consumer electronics then our costs
would be lower and like i'm like okay so
let's say we skip now you're making a
million units a year is it still
expensive if the answer is yes
then
uh
economies of scale are not the issue
do you throw
into manufacturing you throw like supply
chain you talk about resources and
materials and stuff like that do you
throw that into the calculation of
trying to reason from first principles
like how we're going to make the supply
chain work here
yeah yeah and then the cost of materials
things like that or is that too much
exactly so um like another like a good
example of thinking about things uh in
the limit is
um if you take any uh
you know any any
product machine or whatever um
like take a rocket or whatever
and
say if you've got if you look at the
room
raw materials in the rocket um so you're
going to have like uh
aluminum steel titanium inconel
especially
specialty alloys
copper and and you say what are the how
what what's the weight of the
constituent elements of each of these
elements and what is their raw material
value
and that sets the
asymptotic limit for how
low the cost of the vehicle can be
unless you change the materials
so
and then when you do that i call it like
maybe the magic wand number or something
like that so that would be like if you
had the
you know a like just a pile of these raw
materials here and you could wave the
magic wand and rearrange the atoms into
the final shape
um
that would be the lowest possible cost
that you could make this thing for
unless you change the materials
so then and that is always a you're
almost always a very low number
um
so then
the what's actually causing things to be
expensive is how you put the atoms into
the desired shape
yeah actually if you don't mind me
taking a tiny tangent i had a
i often talked to jim keller who was
somebody that worked with you oh yeah
jim was uh yeah did great work at tesla
so
um i suppose he carries the flame of the
same kind of
thinking that you're you're talking
about now
um and i guess i see that same thing at
tesla and
spacex folks who work there they kind of
learn this way of thinking and it kind
of becomes obvious almost but anyway i
had um argument not argument
uh he educated me
about
how cheap it might be to manufacture
teslabot we just we had an argument what
is how can you reduce the cost the scale
of
producing a robot because i've gotten a
chance to interact quite a bit um
obviously in in the academic circles
with humanoid robots and then boston
dynamics and stuff like that and they're
very expensive to to build and then uh
jim kind of schooled me on saying like
okay like this kind of first principles
thinking of how can we get the cost of
manufacture down
um i suppose you do that you have done
that kind of thinking for teslabot and
for all kinds of
all kinds of complex systems that are
traditionally seen as complex and you
say okay how can we simplify everything
down
yeah
i mean i think if you are really good at
manufacturing
you can basically
make at high volume you can basically
make anything for a cost
that asymptotically approaches the raw
material value of the constituents plus
any intellectual property that you need
to license anything right
but it's hard it's not like that's a
very hard thing to do but but it is
possible for anything
anything in volume can be made of like i
said for a cast that asymptotically
approaches this raw material uh
constituents
plus intellectual property license
rights
so what will often happen in trying to
design a product is people start with
the tools and and parts and methods that
they are familiar with and then
and try to create
a product using their existing tools and
methods
the other way to think about it is
uh actually imagine the try to imagine
the platonic ideal of the perfect
product
or technology whatever it might be
and so what is this what is the perfect
arrangement of atoms
that would be the best possible product
and now let us try to figure out how to
get the atoms in that shape
i mean it's it sounds um
it's almost like rick and morty absurd
until you start to really think about it
and it you really should
think about it in this way because
everything else is kind of uh
uh if you if you think uh
you you might fall victim to the
momentum of the way things are done in
the past unless you think in this way
well just as a function of inertia
people will
want to use the same tools and methods
that they are familiar with um
they just that's what they'll do by
default yeah um and then that that will
lead to an outcome of things that can be
made with those tools and methods but it
is unlikely to be the um platonic idea
of the perfect product
um
so
then
so that's why it's good to think of
things in both directions they're like
what can we build with the tools that we
have but then but what also what is the
what is the perfect the theoretical
perfect product look like and that that
theoretical perfect part is going to be
a moving target because as you learn
more
the
definition of or or for that perfect
product will change because you don't
actually know what the perfect product
is but you can successfully approximate
a more perfect product
so think about it like that and then
saying okay now what tools methods
materials whatever do we need to
create in order to get the atoms in that
shape
but people ver
rarely think about it that way
but it's a powerful tool
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you